hey everyone Larry here at drag Con and
I have been waiting all day for this
interview come on it's okay come on
ahead we have some fans in here we're
about to enter the fan arena for miss
Vanessa van G Matteo so we're gonna go
in right now well she's with she's with
she's with a myriad of fans right now
we're gonna head on in right now
Vangie nice to see you again Larry it's
so good to see you
can we come on in right here with you
real quick oh yes wherever the light is
great thank you so much for doing this
with us you have a line that goes around
and around I have been coming here every
single hour upon hour and the line has
grown bigger and bigger what does that
mean
that must feel so great it's a immune
it's a blessing and you can't think
things for granted and it goes to show
you don't have to win to necessarily win
just be yourself and I'm just happy that
there's so many people here tonight that
or today that relate to me and I'm happy
and I'm not I haven't taken a break
neither so y'all way I'm going away with
you I will be here too the power is cut
off honey don't make sure everybody get
a photo you've always been so wonderful
with your fans I mean again it is just
it's such a special moment what do you
hope fans find out or learn more about
you after this season and and going
forward what do you want them to know
about Vanessa Bantry Matteo yeah I feel
like my fans know me now that was like
that was one of my that was one of the
exciting parts about coming back to the
show was getting to last longer than an
episode so the fans can really get to
know me so then by the time I can't by
the time I got eliminated you know at
the last episode I was okay with like I
wasn't okay with it but at my heart of
hearts I felt like well at least people
got to see and meet and know really who
I am and that's why I feel like you know
before here today to see me and I'm here
to meet everyone and celebrate what a
great season it's been and I'm just
happy and I love all the other girls
that's up for it everyone's amazing in
[ __ ] you know I ain't trying to be
politically correct cuz I never am but
[ __ ] I'm happy you're happy you've got
a line around the block can you tell us
a little bit about this space are we or
returning sub dominatrix in here what's
going on Michelle said I whoa mush up
autorad I kept wearing on the season so
I said I'm gonna take the red there's
gonna be a red laundry mat cuz I'm gonna
do all my red swimsuit leotards corsets
we kind of just me and a few of my
friends that we come up with like ideas
and concepts
and I was kind of feeling this and I
said okay everything's gonna be red I'm
gonna be wearing the opposite and of
course has to be a little sexy and it's
got to be Vangie Fifty Shades of
something gotta be 50 shades Wow
I spoke with Evy earlier and she said
one of her favorite outfits on the
runway this season was your Libra look
and she said she especially liked it
because she knows it caused you a little
bit of pain what is your response to
that true I did I hot-glued a little bit
of the headpiece to my head because I
was rushing in the anthem we were we
were like never like two minutes and so
I have glued it [ __ ] I went bald for
like like following episodes I was like
my hair but all for drag honey beauty is
pain beauty is pain I got to ask you the
burning question everybody wants to know
you and Brooklyn are no longer but
you're still very very cordial how are
you doing hit me up if you're I'm single
then I want the note big experience
don't come here with that poster and our
other book I'm a hopeless romantic I
love Brooklyn but you got to move out
other fish in the sea again being on the
prowl can you give us the camera you're
like biggest sales pitch on dating Angie
Mateo
come one come on I don't discriminate
our participate but as the Banshee is
waiting for you call five five five five
the hot pocket you heard it right there
the hot pocket the NASA Vangie Mateo
it's always a privilege always a
pleasure thank you so much it's so good
relations thank you so much